وقفه اخرى للطواقم الطبيه من العاملين في
بريطانيا تضامنا مع فلسطين هم مجموعه من
بين اكثر من ال000 من العاملين في قطاع
الصحه حول البلاد يتوقفون عن العمل في يوم
الحراك الوطني من اجل غزه واقفين بره
المستشفى نفتكر زملائنا في غزه ونتكلم عن
الوضع ونعرف الناس ان احنا كاطباء زي بق
الناس البني ادمين في انجلترا و بق العالم
يعني شايفين الوضع كارثي ولازم يقف حالا
دلوقتي علينا مواصله الضغط على مؤسساتنا
لتتبنى موقفا حازما وتكون رائده اخلاقيا
لوقف هذه الاباده
الجماعيه هذه المجموعه من الاباء الذين
هزتهم صور جثامين الاطفال واشلاء من ضحايا
حرب اسرائيل على غزه اصطحبوا اطفالهم في
هذه الوقت
لعلهم يسمعون اصواتهم للمشرعين بعد قتل
نحو الف فلسطيني كثهم من
الاطفال من المهم ان يحضر ابني هنا لانني
اريد له ان يصبح صوت من لا صوت له عندما
يكبر فهو يفهم ويعلم ان حكومتنا تدعم ما
يحدث ولكننا نرفض ذلك ونريد ان
يتوقف نعارض الاباده الجماعيه المستمره في
غزه ف حكومتنا ليست متواطئه فحسب بل انها
تساعد في ذلك بقطع التمويل نشعر
بالاشمئزاز لاستمرار الرعب في نفوس
الاطفال والمدنيين الابرياء
لكن تمثال نيلسون منديلا المحاد لبرلمان
ويست منستر شعار الديمقراطيه والحريه يبقى
شاهدا على ان الحرب على اطفال غزه علمت
اطفال بريطانيا كيف يكتبون اسم فلسطين
لتفشل محاولات طمسه من الذاكره
البريطانيه في الشارع وفي مكان العمل وعلى
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي يواصل انصار
القضيه الفلسطينيه حملاتهم الشعبيه حتى
تستجيب الحكومه لمطلبهم بالدعوه لوقف فوري
لاطلاق النار استجابه يخشى كثيرون ان تاتي
متاخره لاكثر من مليوني فلسطيني يواجهون
موتا محتو
في ظل استمرار العدوان الاسرائيلي على
قطاع غزه المحاصر م حربلو الجزيره لندن